hi everybody my name is Lee bone strim
I work as a customer engineer for Google
from the Amsterdam office and you will
see me mostly visiting banks and
insurances as we at Google yeah we we
divide our teams in in parts and can
they asked me likely would you like to
go to Paris to give this presentation
about extending G suite functionalities
with business applications and I said
like yeah that'd sure I'm a developer I
love to share my knowledge about yeah
building cool apps so yes I like to go
to Paris are there any developers here
in the room a few um how many people
have ever seen coats or red coat like so
more right okay so this will be a
technical session but I'm gonna share
you all the secrets on how you can build
applications with the use of G Suites
and typically there are two ways in how
you can build applications with G suite
you can take the Apps Script approach
that means like I'm staying within the G
suite domain and I put my own code on
top of that so it is within G suite
let's say Docs or sheets and I put my
own codes within the doc or sheet and
that way I make it more advanced or more
confirm my needs
back in the past people used to use that
like for example in office they use
macros and Visual Basic that way we in G
suite we have Apps Script so that is one
approach the other approach is like I
already have my own existing application
or my own app my website and I like to
take G suite functionalities within my
own app so the benefit is then I'm not
internally within the G Street domain
now I can be on any domain and I just
moved the data from G suite or the
functionalities from G suite within the
app now there's actually another way in
how you can create applications with G
suite and that maybe you've seen it
earlier today in the keynote that is
true app maker and I will show you that
as well app maker is our visual design
yeah
drag-and-drop editor where you very
quickly can create apps you don't need
to be a developer to create applications
so for the people that earlier said like
I've never seen code before yeah you
guys can't create apps as well after
this all I will hand it over to Laura
from luma apps and she will explain what
what they did with their company what
kind of applications they created so
very exciting all right let's start with
the first approach the Apps Script
approach Apps Script and that is a
server for Less JavaScript runtime for
4G suite
that means server less that means not
that there are no servers because there
are servers but there are somewhere in a
Google Data Center and we just don't
care about that but we write JavaScript
code and it's been executed somewhere in
a data center and you can do this to
create your D suite add-ons that is
add-ons for G suite they make use of the
oauth2 model so they are secure within
the G Street domain there is a script
editor within G suite that you can use
where you can start coding your your
code and you can make use of triggers so
for example when you open a document
yeah then it can start executing code
and these add-ons you can bring them to
a marketplace and then you can download
them you can also download them from the
document itself then you go to add-ons
get add-ons and download these add-ons
to make it more yeah
advanced let's look into the entry
points how can I get started with this
with the first entry point that is like
container-bound apps now what is it
contain about app that means like I have
one particular Google Doc or one
particular sheet and every time when I
open that sheet I execute my own code my
own Apps Script code that is a
container-bound application so for one
particular yeah document and you can get
access to a particular document by
running document app don't get active
documents spreadsheet app get active
spreadsheet or a form app get active
form and it has these triggers so every
time when you execute the Iranian the
documents you can execute code or every
time when you edit the document it
executes code the other approach that is
not for a particular document that can
be any documents or any spreadsheet so
you go to script.google.com you get the
editor but your code but you will
execute in this case can be can be for
any documents so usually what people do
is they create like like a picker or a
drop-down where you can select the
document where you want to run your code
on top of or you create a new document
or a new sheet and you run code on that
type of sheet this is typically done for
add-ons like when you download an add-on
from the marketplace they probably chose
this way so I'm not not a
container-bound scripts it's just yeah
regular Apps Script application there is
another way in how you can create code
in Apps Script that is for Adwords
we're not gonna cover that and the last
way is through maker although it is a
visual design drag-and-drop editor it is
still possible to add some code in case
you want to create a really an advanced
application we'll see this later
now how can you write Apps Script code
let's take a look into an example of how
I can create or modify just standard
esuite functionality with my own code
usually what I do is I go look into the
docs in the docs take it give great
guides and they explain the whole api's
that you can start using so I always
have that open in another tab in the
browser and then I finally start writing
code so in in this case what I'm kind of
built is an conference app where I have
like shared slides folder and my
co-workers they can upload a slide in my
folder and every time when when people
uploads slides in the folder I get an
email it's a very simple example but I
think it's a use case like getting an
email based on when a foul has been
edited I think it's a very common use
case so we start doing that we go into
drive where we create a new app script
and that is the file that we will start
use the next thing is we need this
slides folder where people will upload
the files in and to do that we need to
make sure that is shared so within your
drive you can say like ok this is a
shared folder you right-click it you set
a link sharing on and you usually get a
pop-up and it also tells you the idea of
the of the folder that will be shared
and that is the ID that we need to
reference in our code so that our code
knows like ok this is the folder that we
need to start monitoring so there you go
I start writing a variable with the ID
of the folder now the next thing is I
start writing some some logics here and
the first thing that I'm doing here is I
say like ok that folder I'll take that
folder and I'll I'll get the real folder
object and from that folder object I
want to loop through all the files that
are in this folder and I save that to a
variable this will be an array so later
I can look through that array and start
doing things I create another variable
called props and props in this case is
like a very little store where you can
store and yeah data in its like
persistent layers it's very simple but
it's like a way how you can save files
even after you closed the document that
you still can store some information
there and we need to store information
because I need to mark if I have seen
this slide before or not because I don't
want to have by the end of the month
hundreds of emails because it's not in
emailing out the same files every time
all right I create a variable new files
array so here I will say like flag it
like okay this file is new and then I
start looping through all the files that
are in the shared slights folder and
here comes the trick I say like ok if I
have nothing in my prop store so if I
have nothing stored of safety yet then
I'm gonna create a key in this store
that referenced the file that I am
viewing right now and the reason why
I'll do that is so next time I will skip
this if you don't skip it then it adds
it to the new files
ray and when it comes to the new files
arrayed and that's the last thing that
it does it's like okay there are new
files new slides have been uploaded I
need to email these slides that is my
gmail app does this is this is Google
Gmail API there's a standard integrated
within Google Apps Script you can start
making use of these API calls you don't
need to download anything or start out
indicating anything because it's all
standard there okay so in within 20
lines I created this functionality I can
start playing the functionality I run
the play button
I say execute the process function and
yeah I'm good to go right I make sure
that I have logging enabled so every
time when something will be emailed I
will also get a lock message I can do
simple logging that is just read logger
to look but I can also do more advanced
logging and that goes to the Google
Cloud stick driver so if you really want
to have like Road numbers and so yeah
then the stick driver is much much nicer
there you see this is the email how it
will look like in my gmail yeah when I
get the slides it mean email to me now
there was one thing that I did I
executed the the process function once
just for testing purposes but what I
need to do is I need to have this run in
the background so that every time when
somebody uploads the slides that I get
the email so to do that you need
triggers I'm gonna set up a project
trigger and you see this is my first
coat that I created so there is no
trigger created yet so I click on that
link and then it says like yeah you need
to authenticate first you need we need
authorization that this is secure we
don't want everybody to get access to
these Gmail API is without giving that
the permission to write permissions for
it it's all a two so we need to review
the permissions and that's usually that
this is all out of the box it happens
for you so you get this pop-up and then
I say okay I am Lee and I like to
retrieve emails through my Gmail so I
out thereyes Gmail in this case and I
also give you access to
my slides folder which is in drive so I
allowed that now I can finally set up
the triggers and what I'm doing here is
I create a time driven trigger that runs
in the background every five minutes and
then I get the email in case you think
like all this app script I like to try
out with that go ahead there are
actually some extras coming soon we will
have support for Gmail add-ons so if you
want to extend on top of Gmail that is
possible to app script we will have
support for slides so that you can
extend on top of slides here you have a
slides user it might be nice that you
can put your own functionalities on top
of that if you want to try that out
there is an early access program for
this so you can go to this URL and then
you can sign up and you can start
playing around with that and also what's
coming soon
those are mobile add-ons so that Alan's
also run on a mobile phone that's pretty
cool now let's take a look into the
second approach where I said like this
is the approach where you have your own
application and you want to integrate
Google data or gee suite data or gee
suite functionalities within your own
app so your own app on your own website
for example you can do that to the
Google API is google has lots of clients
as the case for you so whether you're a
Java developer or PHP developer or go or
Python or like me JavaScript and node.js
yeah you can download all these SDKs
from the website there are all there and
such an SDK they contain all the Google
endpoints so for all Google products
there are SDK is available so if you
think like I like Google Maps yeah you
can extend your own applications with
Google Maps or you can extend your own
applications with Jesus with Gmail or
Google Docs functionalities this is all
integrated within these client SDKs so
let's take into a look into an example
how you would do this
like I said already I am a notjust
developer so I would prefer a note so
what I do is I go to node package
manager page and I start downloading the
Google API and then the next thing that
you need to do is you need to go to the
Google clouds
yeah control panel and then you look for
that particular API that you want to
make use of so in my case I'm gonna
create a gmail application so I need to
enable the Gmail API within my cloud
console and this way I can monitor and I
can also see like how many times people
have been using my Gmail API so you
enable that in the console the next
thing is you need to set up credentials
this is a very similar process as if you
would create applications in GCP so you
create a service account and you can
download an adjacent key on your machine
and for the Gmail API and for probably
all the other api's then you start
writing code so we're in Apps Script it
went out of the box the owl out
functionality here we need to trigger
that with code and the way how all our
two works in general is like you have
you have this key and with that key you
will login into your Google account so
do you get just a Google pop up you get
a Google pop up when you go to a
particular URL so usually in your
application you create a button it says
like set up set up this functionality
you might remember that from
applications on your mobile phone that
make use of Google and usually it opens
a Google page in the background with the
Google login you need to login into your
Google account and what happens in the
background is this is an after you've
locked into that Google account they
will redirect you to another page but
they have this token being generated and
that token will be written down on your
device or it will be written down on
your machine and that is a bearer token
that later on will give you access to
your Gmail API or to your Google api's
and you usually set it up with an expiry
date
so like the for a certain time frame you
can get
to that API without going through this
process and by logging into Google every
time here you can see an example code
now this is already a little bit more
trickier but honestly it wasn't that
difficult because I just copied it from
the Google Doc site they have for this
example of an OAuth flow and I could
just copy paste it and it works but what
it says basically it says like download
I note yes Google API I need to define
the scope so in this case I'm making use
of Gmail so I manually need to say this
is the Gmail scope vary in Apps Script
it automatically shows up in the pop-up
here I need to type it and sell Google
like this is the scope that I want to
use I also need to specify the path
where on my machine the token will be
stored and then I just copied over the
the methods that will take care of the
authorization and it will work out of
the box and then you can start using
Gmail code and Gmail code that could
look like this for example you say Gmail
deduces that messages that list I
specify my authentication that is the
object that was saved on my machine I
tell who is the user ID that I want to
read to Gmail logics from well in this
case that's me and what am i creating
I'm querying I want to read all the
unread email so I want to get that and I
get that here if it runs wrong it will
log it but if it says ok I will save it
to the emails variable and it in this
case contains email ids and i could look
to those array with ideas and get the
full yeah email bodies and you can yeah
display and you know i use this code
actually for playing around with my
google home that google home can read up
my emails so i did it this way now if
you want to make use of these kind of
stuff there are api's 4G speed for every
G speed product so if I mentioned Gmail
but there are api's for contacts API for
sheets for sites for yeah you name it
everything
alright now we've seen AppMakr and we
have seen Google api's now let's take a
look into our app maker app maker this
is our visual design editor so you don't
need to be a developer to create google
applications you can very quickly drag
and drop it
it's a SAS application that means that
you go to app maker in your browser and
it opens it in the browser and you can
start making use of it it has a bunch of
benefits I mean obviously it's very fast
a fast way to create create applications
this way because yeah you drag-and-drop
components on the stage but it also has
data binding which means that if I
create data in my application and then
you would find a model let's say a model
would be a car let's say I'm gonna
collect cars car information in my app
and then if you would define a car model
you would write out the properties of a
car which is number of wheels the color
the brand so you define the structure of
your yeah of your objects in a model and
because of automatically data binding
it recognizes those data so if you up if
you drag view components on the states
like a table or a grid or a chart it
will automatically recognize the models
where they belong to it and
automatically show it you don't need to
code anything for that it's nicely
integrated within the G Street domain
you can make use of cloud sequel so the
GCP cloud sequel you can implement it in
your apps but if you don't have DCP
cloud sequel and you just want to make
use of G suite alone you can also just
store the data in Google Drive and it's
secure because it's within the Google
domain so all the security rules are
applied in whitelisted to 2g suite
itself so this is not a solution for
creating apps for the Google Play Store
or the iOS app store now this is more a
solution for internal applications
like like an internal HR application or
an internal CRM or tracking applications
there are lots of reasons why businesses
need internal apps that run within their
own firewall and this time they don't
need to hire developers to build these
stuff now they can do it themselves they
can prototype it quickly or they can
even build full life applications so you
don't need to be a developer to make use
of it at this point and click so you can
drag and drop all the components it
supports by open standards so it makes
use of html5 JavaScript CSS and HTML and
it also has the nice material design
look and feel so your applications
really look like Android apps really
nice now yes we're talking about this
now let me give you a demo so I can show
you how this works so can we switch to
my machine please cool so what you see
here this is the website of yeah this is
the SAS application of app maker and I
recorded it myself so I'm make sure that
I can do it within the time frame the
first thing that I'm doing here is I am
changing the application name now what
kind of application are we creating
we're creating a to do application I
think that's the most yeah common
application for when you're new so I
create an application now I'm gonna
select a data model or data object that
like I said you can save data in Drive
or you can save data in in in Google
Cloud sequel I'm gonna create save data
in the Google Drive so I select the
model in the Google Drive let's do that
there are other ways as well but we're
using just drive so I say X elect Drive
and I click Next
now I give a model name here so in this
case the model will be tasks tasks
causes it to do application
I can start creating fields for a task
now what kind of fields do I need I need
to have a task name so I create a string
field for task yeah
I need another field in this case I need
a field for dates because I need to say
like by when this this task needs to be
done so it's a in this case a date field
I create another field this is a boolean
field to mark if the task is completed
yes or no so I called the task filter
completed it's a boolean alright I
switch back to the page this is the
stage I can rename it this will be the
main page so I set it to main yeah I can
start dragging widgets on the stage so
in this case I'm dragging a great
component this is like a little table
did you see it also recognized my model
my task model out of the box this is
true data binding so it already knows
like ok this table will save tasks data
ok I drag it on the stage and you can
change the column headers if you want so
I don't do that right now
I'm gonna select another component on
the stage and in this case it's a form
and this will be the view / edit form so
every time when I select the task in my
grid then I want to showcase in this
form like the information about this
task and when you see what I'm doing now
is I'm resizing everything so that it's
like nicely great sizes I can drag
another button on the stage this button
is for when I create new task and when I
want to create a new task what I want to
do is I want to show a pop-up where I
can start typing so I give the button
the name app automatically if you switch
the style from the button and the button
is called ad then it comes with this
nice plus icon so that already looks
like nice material design ish and now I
can start creating another page this
will be the pop-up so for creating a new
task yes
okay I'll start dragging another
component on the screen and in this case
it's a form this is the at form for
creating new task data again through
data binding it recognizes the the model
I'm just changing the layout here so I
want to make it like a little small I
want to make the model or the pop-up
also small so that it's nicely in the
center of my page I can change the their
whites the spacing here and I said set
the width right okay now I need another
button in this case I want to close the
dialog so and I am NOT filling in any
caste data should be also able to remove
the pop-up so I'm dragging another
button on the stage I give it a name
close then it recognized the cross icon
and and what I'm doing here is I'm
binding an action so what I did is I
said I want to bind the the closed
action on the pop-up so that it
automatically knows that it needs to
close the pop-up there's no code here
just selecting it because app maker
understands that that's just a common
thing to do for a for a pop-up yeah okay
I go back to the main screen I need to
open the pop-up as well so I need to add
also some functionality here I can say
open dialog and then which dialogue well
that's the the add screen I see that I
gave me the wrong name I called it edit
it should be at so I'm changing that to
back to add and then I me to make sure
that also when you have the action that
the action points to the right object so
in this case I need to say the on click
will be on at page yes so I'm sitting at
their open dialogue for the add page
cool
I guess I'm done now I can hit the
preview button and what it does it opens
now my my browser screen if it's the
first time when you do this then you'll
see an
again you will see an Google pop up
where you need to give the the right
permissions I did it already but here
you can see the application running life
and you see these are like the the nice
the components I can start editing data
in it it created new tasks and when I
select a task I can you see that it's
been highlighted in the in the view
screen and I can hit complete it and it
marks it also in the integrate that it
was completed so that is true data
binding it took me about five minutes
and again you've seen there's not much
coding here let me switch back to my
slides yeah so what I just did there was
no coding involved but I can imagine
that there are use cases that you do
want to write app script code or you do
want to write JavaScript code maybe
because you want to make use of other
google api s-- like the like Gmail for
example you want to integrate that in
your apps that is possible there is a
script editor in apps maker and you can
start writing your codes
this can be Apps Script Apps Script code
so again the surfer less Java scripts
that run somewhere in the Google Data
Center or it can be normal JavaScript
code and then it runs in the browser
alright in case you think like oh I like
to try this out this app maker you can
sign up for the early access program so
you can start playing around with this
and create your own applications just go
to this URL and I think somebody will
approve it and then you can start using
app maker within your own G suite domain
and with this I like it to hand it over
to Laura from loom ops because they
created lots of nice business
applications as well give me a big hand
thank you Thank You Lee
so I'm Laura I'm marketing operations
manager at La Maps and I'm very excited
to be here first of all what is Lim Apps
Lilith's in a nutshell is a social
intranet recommended by Google it's a
combination of an intranet and a social
network we fully integrate with Jay
suite and you can use WA Maps on any
mobile device and we have two core
features that are pretty cool we have a
user directory and we have personalized
content meaning that the user gets the
right content at the right time and it
gets delivered to the right person
so more than words I'm going to show you
a quick version you could connect all
employees in a smart intranet that Islam
apps Lum Apps is a completely reimagined
enterprise portal that delivers the
right content to the right people at the
right time
Lum Apps brings all your communication
together in one place corporate news
profiled information key figures and
social media feeds it's all there it's
about having access to your Google Apps
in one click a quick glance at your
emails or calendar let you know what's
important in your working day we know
how valuable your business applications
are so all the tools you already use
integrate directly into a dashboard a
global search puts what you're looking
for in your hands instantly connecting
with the right people has never been
easier reach out and start working
together Lum Apps notifies you when an
item needs your attention and shows
important topics directly in your
activity stream follow people and join
projects to stay informed in real time
and share ideas whenever you want with
the power of Google Analytics you can
measure the adoption to make sure all
employees love their portal spread your
corporate culture by designing a place
that fits your brand identity
join hundreds of companies who have
already transformed the way they work
with Lum apps so while um apps what
makes Lum apps so special first of all
let's go back to our users and our
customers what are they telling us if
you work for a big organization you work
in IT you're a communication specialist
where are the pain points that are you
gonna face when using an intranet and
when dealing with intranet first of all
the interaction capabilities are very
very limited with my internet platform
if you think of what is the purpose of
an intranet it's a database so you want
to find the right documents the right
people but you also want to start a
conversation with your employees and
Sarge's develop developing a sense of
community so if there's no interaction
capability you have a problem next pain
point is I can't use my internet on
mobile devices this is specifically true
for organizations that work in retail or
distribution or people who work remotely
if they can access and use your internet
for mobile devices you have a problem
the next problem is pretty generic and
common its employees rarely use my
internet turns out maybe I can't use my
internet on mobile devices or it's
currently not being used next problem is
my internet is just a page of links so
it's very good if you're looking for the
right document but how can I engage my
employees and exchange with them next
pain point is pretty critical is the
look and feel of my intranet is old and
outdated it's specifically true for
companies who are who are very
innovative so from the outside you want
to reflect an image of being an
innovative company but if you're from
the inside you're not innovative then
you have a problem you want to have a
platform that's modern and that has a
modern look and feel the search function
is broken could be a problem if I'm
looking for a person I'm looking for a
document that's
critical for my project or for my
business the last pain point is also
really really important is you're gonna
have businesses who are gonna want to
have all their applications in one place
so if my internet does not integrate all
the business apps and all the apps are
very very critical for all my entities
turns out my internet is not going to be
used as well so we've covered the
problems and now we come to the solution
the solution is ylim apps you have three
cree-cree points EULA Mac is the unique
digital workplace
where a user gets delivered the right
content to the right person at the right
time we integrate with Jay suite very
deeply and you also have the social
collaborative functions are integrated
in the platform besides those three
points the Maps is responsive meaning
that you have the same quality of
information on any device that you're
connecting to its multilingual in the
sense that the content is displayed with
the language of the connected user you
can customize the maps to your liking
with a personalized graphical identity
depending on your brand identity as well
and if you're an internet project leader
you might want to analyze the way people
use your platform and react so that's
when the analytic picture features of La
Maps comes in I'm going to go over four
simple use cases to show you what our
customers are doing with la maps the
first customer is via a civilian is our
first historical customer it's a French
international company they have
activities around energy and utilities
and they have external growth they grow
externally a lot so they need to develop
a sense of belonging and a sense of
community to all their employees so we
created the first internet portal for
them named one vilya one Veolia means
one unique entry point you have a one to
one conversation with every vilya
employee one also means a single place
to get corporate information and local
information they've also developed a top
500 portal dedicated to the
five hundred managers where they publish
premium information so they allow
sensitive relevant and critical content
to be delivered to the top 500 managers
and they will they will also want to
increase the engagement of those top 500
managers one of other one of our other
customers is also another industrial
giant its value value is the leader in
auto parts manufacturing and they're
also early adopters of innovative cloud
technologies so they go google in 2007
and they also went all digital they
created 18,000 Google Sites so they were
looking for a best-in-class application
in terms of intranet projects and so
they chose low maps for its modern look
and feel they also really liked the
profiling functionality which I've told
you earlier about providing the right
content to the right person at the right
time they've created the top 300
management corporate portal and they
also use the social capabilities of low
Maps in the sense that they've created
collaborative platform for all the RNG
teams no matter where you are in the
world you have all the information
within this community we change worlds
we go to Capel Capel is the French
agricultural cooperative cooperative
means that people are scattered around
the territory so you need to create
engagement with a sense of community and
they want to drive traffic to their
intranet and they've used two drivers
which are pretty cool they've used our
users directory which means that you can
launch for example from the users
directory function you can launch a
hangout or send an email directly from
someone's profile all the changes that
you make are also directly synced with
Google they've also used a second driver
to drive traffic to their intranet
internal as so they've developed an
internal liberal kua or internal eBay to
let other employees know that they're
selling their car or they're selling the
real estate and they've also developed
internal ads for carpooling
they want to share rice with other
employees and the last use case I want
to present is item so you probably all
know this brand it's a fashion or a
French clothing retailer they have more
than 4,000 stores in 52 countries so the
information is spread in fill operation
and there's no real connection to
corporate headquarters they go Google
and they need to extend the use of
Google applications they want to go
further in collaboration so they choose
web Maps and they choose Lamaze because
we integrate fully with all Google
applications they also choose loo maps
because in every store you have two to
three tablets that the employees in the
stores use so they were packed
particularly sensitive to the fact that
we integrate also any mobile device
they've chosen a name for the intranet
which is called Lanka and Lanka is
dedicated to four stores and it has four
different spaces for example there's a
there's a space for brand there's a
space also for the high corporate
headquarters speaking to the field
operations so I thought I would just
show you with a visual summary what
limits does so you have all the devices
that we connect at the centre we
integrate the business apps you get
corporate and local news delivered
directly to your computer your tablet or
your smartphone you have this user
directory with an organism a
organizational charts also embedded the
social community and the communities
that you can create and also integrates
integration with Google Drive now we
know what we sell you know our products
I thought I would share something about
who we are and what's our story so this
is us we're about 70 people and
constantly growing we have offices in
Paris London New York San Francisco and
we recently opened Austin and Tokyo we
have a worldwide partners of partners
network and this year we raised funds we
raised eight million dollars and this is
an article that was published last
week in Lisak ooh you can find it online
and it explains our philosophy our
strategy and you can also get to know
our founders we started our business in
2015 by addressing G sweet customers in
2016 we were lucky enough to be
officially recommended for G suite by
Google what does it mean to be
officially recommended by Google it
means that Google and ylim apps product
teams are working together to align
their product roadmaps it also means
that Lowe Maps is built on the Google
cloud platform and we meet Google
standards in terms of security and it
means that ylim apps provide a full
integration with j suite and this full
integration is certified by Google
itself and in 2006 17 during the Google
cloud summit in San Francisco we
received the solution innovation of the
Year award
so from this side you can see that we
have a whole bunch of customers what's
important to note is that we address all
sizes all industries and we can also
address companies that are present
globally we have over 35 percent market
share now in France and today around 1.4
million people used to use the maps
daily so that's it for me
if you want to know more you can write
me an email
or you can go to our booth where booth
number five is right across the hall and
also one last cool feature is that you
can download limb apps from the Google
marketplace for a free trial so you can
test try and have fun with the product
for 30 days so you go should go and
check it out thank you for your time
thanks